it's time for a special early edition of
there's just so much good stuff we have
to get to we have to do Friday Follies
on a Thursday we didn't have time to do
a new graphic all right give us a break
first up one of the great traditions of
flying is no more at least on one
airline it's my favorite airline you
know telling me this to explain we're
joined by New York Times bestselling
author the wheel Wilder series at Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo reign
and so Southwest Airlines has taken away
our peanuts they have taken away our
what it is awful subsist on flying at
the top of August and I collect those
things I take them on to the kids that's
the that's the same person it takes the
shampoo and conditioner I don't know but
I do take those honey roasted peanuts I
love well I get on the plane and the
Southwest attendant tells me we're not
serving those anymore I said you're
gonna pretzels that you can have these
veggie chips I said I want you to chips
they put out a statement I'm gonna read
it to you this is outrageous
peanuts forever will be part of
Southwest history and DNA however to
ensure the best onboard experience for
everyone you can put up the full
statement there it is especially for
customers with peanut related allergies
we have made the difficult decision to
discontinue serving peanuts on all
flights beginning August 1st and they
say they want peanuts allergy sufferers
to feel safe and welcomed on Southwest
what about me I am a animal allergy now
I am allergic to cats and dogs do you
know only 1% of Americans are allergic
to peanuts 30% of us are allergic to
cats and dogs and the aisles are choked
with service animals and emotional
support animals if there's an explosion
first of all that peanut allergies are
very serious Raymond Arroyo so we have
to be very mindful of that I have a
question and what are peanut related
allergies I've heard of peanut but what
are they related to there's dust in the
air what are they gonna do I don't know
what happens but I do know what happens
when I get on board and a lady's got the
netted little carry-on and there's a cat
in there I see those little devil eyes
looking up at me the sciences do this
but I love pulled the
data for you really but 700 service
animals fly everyday 281,000 service
animals a year on most carriers 750 1000
emotional support lightest animals wait
and now these this is a newfangled thing
and and I really think it's so people
can get around the airfares for their
pets wait a second did that horse make
did that horse make it on a plane I do i
I have seen a trend in people bringing
on no I'm not talking about the little
tiny dogs I'm talking about the big
Mastiff type time I had an Irish
Wolfhound literally two rows in front of
all we need to say it's like a man sir
in the role I don't know how you can let
that beast put a small horse people
treat the dogs then like an ottoman
because there aren't they have to there
are that's a good ottoman do you
remember Dexter this was the the
emotional support peacock the woman
tried to get on United Airlines earlier
this year that's his video of it she
actually tried to get the the peacock on
board United Airlines told her in
January no and Laura we're gonna have to
have a quick moment of silence because
Dexter we learned this week has died
that's our moment of silence I think
what I need is an emotional support dog
or cat catcher to spare my allergy so I
feel safe and well the peanut allergy
people they're protected but the the the
30% of Americans who are pet allergy
sufferers they just have to you gotta
eat veggie chips and suffer this is the
Instagram post about Dexter we have to
give Dex oh no no don't worry about day
so that's a that's a so boring it's very
a severe that the owner is he is
survived he is survived by his sisters
Ava pictured here and Zsa Zsa and by all
humans who loved him Dexter you will
forever be missed and remembered
remembered with fondness and love of sad
never heard a peacock mate do the mating
sounds of peacocks anything to do with
peacocks the best thing about Dexter is
now it's feathers gonna be displayed in
the foyer okay go ahead
alright well
you have an update for us on the straw
crusade sweeping the country I hate
plastic straws myself I think papers
fine okay
some celebrities have made a video of
course warning of the dire impact of
plastic straws on whales in sea life
watch 500 million plastic straws are
used in this country every single day
and many end up in the ocean polluting
water and killing sea life if we don't
act now by 2050 there will be more
plastic in the ocean than fish now do
you know where that number comes from
the 500 million number a little boy
named Milo Chris he was a nine year old
in 2011 he did a science project he
called around all the straw
manufacturers they gave him an estimate
one of them said 500 million or so he
took it that's what they ran with here
he is on CNN watch every straw we use
every piece of plastic will be here on
earth somewhere on earth even when my
grandchildren are born I started the
project to reduce the number of straws
that go into our landfills every day can
you imagine this adorable yeah well now
that little adorable kid has managed to
outlaw plastic straws in Malibu
Seattle Santa Barbara they'll send you
to jail for it so they're its people
well I was just in Malibu and they are
now introducing pasta straws they had
pasta noodles and straws stuck in the
water Laura what's wrong with you drink
it your water tastes like day-old
rigatoni that's the problem with it it's
really bad now I have a suggestion
oh no that I took that picture that's an
actual pasta store it gets soggy but it
does destroying our ocean so I have an
idea with that I hate plastic all over
the beaches it's horrible for the marine
life don't use as much we got rid of
plastic bottles at my heart I have an
idea you're going to like well I think
we need beef jerky straws which we can
bring on planes will drink out of those
and then feed them to all the service
and emotional support in other words I
beef flavored water would be my idea I
don't want any food stuff what about
people with wheat allergies beef
allergies they should be considered or
even a Royale the the malcontents flyer
here on here
from angle thanks so much Raymond